Qué importancia estratégica tiene La
Represa de kahobka y Qué consecuencias
Podría tener su voladura
Muchas gracias por por la invitación
Bueno estamos ante una situación de un
posible ataque de Rusia Creo que este o
volar las centrales hidroeléctricas
causaría problemas significativos para
ambas partes y entonces lo que sí
estamos viendo Es como Rusia Está
tratando de disminuir la capacidad
energética de Ucrania de que ya se está
acercando el invierno y en este sentido
obligar al gobierno de selenski a
sentarse a negociar una salida política
al conflicto pero si vuelan la presa
pues estarán teniendo problemas los
mismos rusos Por lo cual creo que se
están un poco aventurados los
comentarios del presidente ucraniano
precisamente por esto último que Comenta
le quería preguntar ve factible que
Rusia esté realmente pensando en volar
la presa no sería también un error
estratégico que podría terminar
afectando a la Península de crimea
Pues sería un error catastrófico yo
supondría que están tomando contra
medidas los efectivos prorrusos y
efectivos rusos para evitar que La
Represa caiga en manos de la ofensiva
ucraniana si los rusos mantienen el
control o lo que apunta a que se está
planeando esto es a reducir el
suministro energético a la digamos a la
Ucrania que no está ocupada por el
ejército ruso entonces yo voy más en la
medida o en el sentimiento de que es una
confrontación que está de cara al
invierno para poder suministrar la
energía suficiente a los hogares
ucranianos para que puedan sobrellevar
los meses de Diciembre enero y febrero
sí y en otro tema relacionado con
Ucrania el ministro de energía ucraniano
denunció que Rusia ha atacado al menos
ya la mitad de la capacidad de
generación térmica del país y que en
total entre el 30 y el 40% de la
infraestructura energética ucraniana
habría sido atacada vamos a escuchar sus
palabras y seguimos con usted
esta semana especialmente esta semana
apuntaron a varias centrales eléctricas
entonces puedo decirles que el volumen
total de Electricidad que no se
suministra es decir que se pierde en
Esta generación es de alrededor de 4000
megawatts
Time Qué consecuencias está teniendo
esto ya en el día a día de los
ucranianos
Pues bueno Lamentablemente desde que
inició la operación militar rusa o la
guerra en Ucrania la vida de los
ucranianos ha ido en detrimento Y estos
son los esfuerzos que tiene el ejército
ruso para obligar a los políticos
ucranianos a que se sienten y que
busquen una salida ya negociada al
conflicto si le reducimos la capacidad
de generación eléctrica entonces también
el gobierno ucraniano tiene que decidir
si manda esa energía eléctrica a los
hogares ucranianos o si es energía
eléctrica se va hacia las armas y hacer
los aparatos de y las contramedidas que
tiene Ucrania y que ha desplegado para
evitar los ataques contra de drones o
los ataques aéreos por parte del
ejército ruso entonces para este ser o
todo apunta a que la estrategia rusa ha
cambiado ya no tener un enfrentamiento
Cuerpo A Cuerpo con el ejército
ucraniano sino empezar a desgastar las
posibilidades de la auxilio que pueda
tener el ejército de selenski y mientras
se busca una salida a la guerra que
pueden hacer Ucrania y sus socios para
paliar esta situación de cara al
invierno que ya llega a Europa Bueno
aquí
tendría que también los países europeos
tomaron una decisión muy fuerte los
europeos se supone que tienen hasta el
momento
gas para 72 días o que hay reservas de
gas para 72 días de cara al invierno y
pues el gas que proviene de Estados
Unidos está saliendo cada vez más caro
el gas licuado cuesta cuatro veces más
de lo que cuesta el gas en ruso Entonces
sería una cuestión de tratar de
delimitar